G
WITH IT.  AINS.
>> Steve: STAY TUNED, LET'S SEE.
>> Ainsley: CHUCK SCHUMER ASK IN
A RESTAURANT IN D.C.
>> Steve: A PLACE ON CAPITOL
HILL WHERE A LOT OF HIGH ROLLERS
ON CAPITOL HILL COME AND THEY
HAVE SOME DRINKS AND THEY HAVE
FUN AND SOMETIMES THEY TALK
REALLY LOUD.
>> Brian: WASHINGTON?
>> Steve: YEAH.
>> Ainsley: HE WAS SPEAKING
REALLY LOUDLY AT THIS DINNER
TABLE.
CHUCK SCHUMER.
CHRIS COONS AND MARK KELLY AND
JOHN HICKENLOOPER, DICK DURBIN
AND A FEW OTHERS.
HE IS SITTING AT THIS TABLE AND
TALKING LOUDLY ACCORDING TO
SOURCES SEVERAL PEOPLE CONFIRMED
IT.
MULTIPLE SOURCES THEY WAS
OVERHEARD BY PATRONS.
HERE IS WHAT HE WAS SAYING A
WHOLE LIST OF THINGS.
NOT ONLY IS NANCY PELOSI IN
TROUBLE BECAUSE DEMOCRATS ARE
GOING TO LOSE THE HOUSE.
HE SAID THERE IS A 60% CHANCE
THAT WE HOLD THE SENATE, MEANING
DEMOCRATS AND A 40% CHANCE THAT
WE HOLD THE HOUSE.
HE SAID KEVIN McCARTHY
SUCKINGS UP TO FORM EVERYWHERE
PRESIDENT DONALD TRUMP.
HE BELIEVED TRUMP WOULD RUN FOR
RE-ELECTION IN 2024.
DO YOU WANT TO TAKE OVER AND
READ A FEW?
>> Steve: YOU MENTIONED KEVIN
McCARTHY.
SEE WHAT HE HAS TO SAY ABOUT
THIS NEWS, KEEP IN MIND, NANCY
PELOSI JUST RECENTLY SAID NOT
ONLY WILL THE DEMOCRATS KEEP THE
HOUSE, THE DEMOCRATS WILL ADD
MEMBERS.
THAT'S WHAT SHE SAID.
THEN YOU GOT CHUCK SCHUMER IN A
RESTAURANT TALKING LOUD SAYING
NOPE, THE HOUSE IS GONE.
SHE MENTIONED -- HE MENTIONED
KEVIN McCARTHY.
HERE HE IS RIGHT HERE ON THE
CHANNEL.
>> WE'RE GOING TO UNITE AMERICA
WITH A PLAN.
WE HAVE A PLAN TO RESTORE
AMERICA TO WHERE WE NEED TO BE.
THE COMMITMENT TO AMERICA.
WHERE WE WILL SECURE OUR BORDER.
LOWER OUR GAS PRICE.
MAKE US ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
BRING BACK THE SUPPLY CHAIN FROM
CHINA TO AMERICA TO CREATE
AMERICAN JOBS.
WE WILL LET PARENTS HAVE A
PARENTS BILL OF RIGHTS SO THEY
HAVE A SAY IN THEIR KIDS'
EDUCATION.
AND THEN WE ARE GOING TO HOLD
THESE GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTABLE.
>> Brian: BY THE WAY NANCY
PELOSI EVIDENTLY WANTS TO BE THE
AMBASSADOR TO ITALY.
>> Ainsley: I DON'T BLAME HER ON
THAT ONE.
THE FOOD IS THE BEST FOOD IN THE
WORLD THERE.
>> Brian: IF KEVIN McCARTHY
DOES BECOME SPEAKER OF THE
HOUSE.
I NEVER HEARD OF A GUY FROM
BROOKLYN SPEAKING LOUDLY AT
DINNER.
>> Steve: SOME OF THE OTHER
THINGS, THESE ARE TIDBITS THAT
PUNCH BOWL REPORTING THE
DEMOCRATS WILL NOT BE ABLE TO
PICK UP A WIN IN IOWA.
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID.
>> Ainsley: CAN YOU IMAGINE IF
YOU ARE MIKE FRANKEN HE DOESN'T
THINK HE CAN BEAT CHUCK
GRASSLEY.
>> Steve: CHUCK GRASSLEY IS
GOING TO WIN, IS HE FUNDRAISING
LEFT AND RIGHT.
MARK KELLY THE SENATOR FROM
ARIZONA WAS AT THE TABLE AND
CHUCK SCHUMER SAID THE ARIZONA
SENATE RACE WOULD TIGHTEN IF
PETER DIEHL THE BILLIONAIRE TECH
GUY STARTED SPENDING MONEY ON
REPUBLICANS.
>> Brian: HE LOVES BLAKE MASTER.
>> Steve: IT'S GOING TO TIGHTEN
ACCORDING TO CHUCK SCHUMER.
CHUCK SCHUMER AND MANCHIN HAVE
HAD A STRANGE RELATIONSHIP.
HE SAID JOE MANCHIN'S CLAIM THAT
TAXING THE RICH IS LIKE
INFLATION FOR THE WEALTHY
AMERICANS, HE SAID THAT IS
RIDICULOUS.
SO, A LOT OF THIS STUFF THAT
THEY SAY ON TV IS DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THEY SAY IN A FANCY ITALIAN
RESTAURANT WHERE EVERYBODY
HAVING A LOT OF FUN, DRINKING A
GLASS OR TWO OF WINE.
>> Ainsley: HE ALSO CRITICIZED
MR. CUOMO FOR REDISTRICTING.
THE FUNNY THING IS HE WILL SAY
ALL OF THAT ALLEGEDLY AT THE
DINNER TABLE.
BUT WHEN THE MEDIA CALLS HIS
OFFICE TO GET A COMMENT, THEY
SAY WE DECLINE.
>> Brian: DO YOU KNOW WHY IT IS?
BECAUSE IT HAPPENED AND IT'S ALL
TRUE AND HE CAN'T DENY IT.
>> Ainsley: TO BE A FLY ON THE
WALL WELL NOW YOU ARE.
>> Brian: NO REASON TO BE A
WAITER.
>> Ainsley: NO REASON IF YOU ARE
GOING TO HAVE THAT KIND AFTER
CONVERSATION YOU SHOULD MAYBE
ASK FO